oh man oh my goodness that's crazy okay
don't listen anymore oh man so smooth
and it like
hey guys it's max and i just spent over
600
on these headphones and this cable so
today
we're not only going to open this up and
take a list and i'll give you guys my
impressions on the sound quality the
active noise cancellation and all the
other features of these headphones
but i'm going to be running a few tests
that nobody has done yet
we're gonna be testing out can you just
use the little
lightning to three and a half mil
adapter with the regular cable
and can you use the usbc charging cable
to run them off of say
your macbook pro or another device let's
go ahead and open it up and
i'm going to flip it to this side i
don't want to be showing off
that bra on the back there at first i
thought it just looked like a purse and
you guys had to comment
about the bra now that's forever stuck
in my head let's go and open these up
ooh this box has a nice little embossing
on there that's nice
oh and by the way we're going to be
doing a comparison to the bose 700s and
the sony xm4s
and with that also against my airpod
pros that i absolutely
love so make sure you guys click that
subscribe button and enable
notifications
but for this one i want to focus on do
these headphones
sound like headphones that should be
priced 550
first impressions they look pretty big
in this box and i love how with apple
products as soon as you open it up you
see your product that you just
spent a ton of money on right away let's
go ahead and pull these up and
jeez louise that has a lot of
heft and weight to it let's go ahead and
peel off this little bra
protector they're using the wax paper
now
wow that's thick down here it's like a
thick layer of plastic
let's get that out of the way this
silicone rubber
feels very very nice and
it looks like we have some cardboard
protecting the cups as well
that magnet is quite strong that's nice
let's go ahead and take this little bra
off all right actually
that just got a lot lighter all right so
this thing
is pretty hefty and that's probably
because there are actually like little
sensors in here
there's magnets so there's a lot going
on even though it looks
kind of weird and let's slip these back
in and i want to point out that we have
a little cutout right here so you can
still charge
while they're inside of the case and
before i put the case away i just want
to mention that i do not
love these cutouts over here i know it
makes it easier to put in
but i'm just worried about this being
exposed and scratching if you throw
these in your backpack
or you're just using this as a case so
let's go ahead and set this
aside and the headphones themselves
actually get quite a bit lighter without
the case
and the outsides here the cups are all
aluminum they're cold to the touch
because it was outside now wow
these ear cups are incredibly soft i
just press on them lightly with my thumb
and they go in and they're also like a
memory foam
that is interesting and these ear cups
are magnetic so let's go take these out
wow okay so that's actually pretty easy
to take off doesn't require too much
effort
looks like if you pull straight up it
won't come off if you twist lightly
comes off very easily and then it just
pops right into
place this is like the year of magnets
and i have to say that it is really
genius
for these ear cups just be able to
easily remove them like this
take a look inside we have sensors one
in each ear cup so
the headphones know when you put them on
and there's a little cut up top i'm not
sure exactly what that is
could be the microphone that actually
constantly listens to what you're
hearing and adjust it so there's no
distortion
and they sound their best and there are
actually nine microphones overall so
we're going to test out the active noise
cancellation
before i put these ear cups back on we
see the large 40 millimeter drivers
inside here as well protected by this
grille and then a really fine screen
as well moving on to the band it feels
really nice the kind of rubberized
finish and surprisingly they're not
picking up fingerprints
as much as i expected i don't really see
anything from my fingers
now this little interesting unique top
band
little cloth material is also ultra
ultra soft it's almost like it's
rubbery kind of springing it just to my
fingers whenever i touch it the airpods
max
also have a pivoting point at the top
but it takes a surprising amount of
pressure
to push them back so i'm guessing that
that's going to create a really tight
solid fit
around your ears and now let's try this
adjustable band
oh wow that takes a lot more pressure
than i expected
i have to push pretty dang hard to get
these to move so that means
you're not gonna accidentally pull these
and mess up your adjustment
and as far as controls we have apple's
digital crown and one single
button to toggle between the active
noise cancellation and the transparency
mode
now before we connect these i just have
to say that i've messed around with a
lot of
higher end headphones and these are by
far the best
built with the solid aluminum that's
cnc'd and then we have the stainless
steel
the materials feel fantastic apple went
all
out on the materials i just have two
worries
first if you don't use the little bra
case
i feel like you could get scratches here
especially on these darker colors where
you might notice it more
and the second is with the extra weight
compared to other headphones
are they going to be less comfortable
after you're using them for say two
three four hours and i'm gonna have to
answer that in my
long term review so make sure you guys
have notifications enabled
to see that let's go ahead and pair them
i don't know if i need to put it on but
i'll just hold down on this active noise
cancellation button
oh there we go all right now for the
moment of truth i feel a little bit
nervous
and you know what to be honest i don't
want to like these
i would not want to buy these for this
price unless you're making videos
and i'm just kind of hoping that they
suck and then i could just
return them but i don't feel like they
will so
let's try it on
so i can't hear any of the ac noise
at all and as far as i remember with the
previous headphones that i tested
i would always still hear a little bit
also surprisingly
i don't feel you know as much ways that
i expected they feel a little bit
lighter
but of course i just put them on we
haven't used these for a couple hours
yet just to make sure you know they did
go into active noise cancellation
automatically
and the only thing i can hear right now
is my mild case of tinnitus
if only they can get that out that would
be perfect
what the heck okay i just pressed the
little button
when i was trying to adjust them this is
wild vadim say something
hey okay so i can slightly tell
very slightly that it's going through a
mic
that is that is good that transparency
mode oh
i just covered up one of the mics and it
changed the transparency mode
i put these back into active noise
cancellation mode sorry if i'm talking
too quiet i'm trying to talk loud
we're going to start out with a max tech
classic where we started from by lost
sky
i want to display a couple of these no
copyright songs so you guys can follow
along and hear what i'm hearing
before i do more listening so let's go
ahead and start playing it back
we're at half volume right now
[Music]
okay sounds good i'm gonna kick it up a
little bit
okay okay this is weird i can't hear my
voice at all
you know what video this reminds me of
the home pod
that deep rich base and now it's maxi's
out
[Music]
it's very interesting that the high
frequencies
okay i gotta i gotta pause this i that
is so weird
i i can't talk because i don't hear my
voice at all i feel like i'm
talking nonsense it's very interesting
that the high notes there
they're not ultra sharp in crisp if you
guys know from our previous videos the
recent macbooks
they've made them a little bit quieter
and they cut down on the high notes a
little bit to make it more balanced and
not as harsh
and that's what i'm hearing here the
vocals sound great
the bass is rich and deep but not
overpowering
and it just sounds very well balanced
with this song
now one of my biggest questions was
sound leakage if you're on an airplane
you have people next to you
can you turn up the volume without
annoying them
so let's go ahead and test that out
we're not going to play the background
track so you guys can hear through the
shotgun mic
that's literally right above me vadim's
going to take a listen
as well so starting out i have this at
about 75
volume can you hear anything video
nothing
no nothing okay let me kick it up a
little bit more
this is about 90 can you hear anything
yeah i could hear a little bit i could
hear some kind of just
whispering i have no idea what you just
said but let's go to 100
okay now we're maxed out this is
probably a little bit too loud
i love loud music but it's pretty dang
loud what can you hear
so i can hear the music but i can't hear
the lyrics so i don't know what it's
saying
all right say that again what basically
i can hear the music but i can't
unders i can't make out the lyrics at
all like it's kind of like
muffled in to be honest i really can't
hear much
even this far away yeah you're you're at
a good
i don't know six feet away this is maxed
out and like i said i
love listening music i max everything on
my earpod pros
and this is probably a little bit too
loud at least with this song so
that is fantastic no issues as far as
air of sound leakage and we did hear
that there's actually a vent in these
just like the airpod pros
so that there's too much pressure it
lets some of that out and that's what
can
let a little bit of sound escape as well
i actually remember the beats solo pros
where i could literally make out the
lyrics and hear exactly what they're
saying but with these
nothing yeah that's interesting because
these are material they're cloth and
they're so soft
but they do a great job all right let's
go ahead and switch to our second song
this is another song that we've really
been enjoying lately you guys will be
able to hear it as well
it's kind of a classical song with some
bass added
sounds really good it's going to pop
these bad boys on
and then as i'm listening i'll also
toggle between the active noise
cancellation and the ambient mode to see
if we could tell a difference in sound
quality
alright songs kicking in
wow
remaxed out it's a little a little loud
actually
[Music]
i'm gonna turn it down by one click
the piano notes sound really good
and that little hi-hat or whatever that
little
is that sounds so crisp sounds very
clean
it's interesting that with the vocals
they didn't sound harsh
but the crispness really comes out here
so let's go ahead and switch to ambient
mode
[Music]
not ambient mode transparency mode
and i'm not really telling i can't tell
a difference in sound quality
oh that sounds really good
okay that sounds really nice
okay and what's very
interesting let me turn this down a
little bit
i had the volume up 90 there and with
the active noise cancellation i can't
hear
anything can't hear my voice even at 90
but when i go to ambient it's this crazy
mix of
my voice sounding exactly how my voice
sounds
and the music being really loud like
they're fusing it together but it sounds
natural which i haven't experienced
with any other headphones okay let's
take these off for a sec
so thankfully like with some headphones
when you go to active noise cancellation
you get worse bass the sound quality
gets worse
some it gets better because you don't
have extra sounds like with the airpod
pros
these sound exactly the same regardless
now of course those are really
compressed tracks off of
youtube so i'm going to jump into title
we're going to listen to some hi-fi
tracks
i have some classical here and also some
master tracks
i can't play it back on youtube so i'm
going to spend a little bit of time
taking a listen to these
songs and then i'll give you guys my
final first impressions on
the sound quality and if it's worth 550
dollars all right guys i just spent a
good amount of time listening
to a variety of different songs genres
i listen to some rock some classical
some hip hop i have actually some
instrumentals i listen to interstellar
soundtrack
so the first thing that really impresses
me
is the sound stage and if you haven't
really
experienced that i guess a lot of
headphones the sound is just in one spot
just
going into your ears this sounds very
wide
you have almost like you're in the room
with speakers all around you
and you can place like the voice kind in
the center little instrumentals going in
different parts
so that sounded fantastic now the next
thing that really surprised me
is how in different songs the highs act
differently now it's for example no time
to die
it's a master track the vocal sounds
smooth
not harsh at all but other songs i don't
say they
sound harsh but they're a lot more crisp
and it just sounds like
it however the artist wanted you to hear
those
songs that's how you hear them with
certain headphones all the high sound
just very crisp
other ones there's not enough so that
was very interesting
bass was also very prominent never
overpowering
and for example in this song set me free
a lot of times i'll listen to that in my
truck because my truck has 19 speakers
all around
and the separation between different
instruments is the best
compared to airpod pros and other
headphones but
man the separation between the electric
guitar
the drums the vocals i haven't heard it
be
that good ever it sounded fantastic so
overall i'm very impressed i definitely
want to hear
20 more songs i want to compare with a
bunch of headphones
just to see how they are but i am very
impressed
the next thing that i want to do is i
know vadim
you love the song strobe i listened to
two versions there's actually a version
with like a symphony as well i don't
know if you heard that one
but i'll let you listen to the original
because you loved that on your homepod
you listened to a bunch of different
songs in your homepod once you got that
so how do you get somebody to spend 550
600 bucks that they don't want to spend
by handing these
over so go ahead and sit down and take a
listen
let's do it hey guys it's vadim and it
was really interesting recording this
because i can
see max listening to it but i can't hear
it so this is exciting
and with dead mouse strobe this song's
very long it's a 10 minute song but
there's one specific area
in the intro where a lot of speakers
distort because it's a really weird low
note
and on the homepod i was really
surprised because it played it back
so well and so clean and i love that
about the home pods so
it's moment of truth these are really
comfortable wow
it's crazy like the sound like
goes back and forth like the stereo is
so good
yeah i know you can't hear me right now
but i definitely noticed that
it's it's really weird the sound stage i
can't hear you you're good you're good
you keep listening
oh wow oh that's amazing
oh that's crazy oh no
oh it's christmas time
uh vadim has been trying not to buy them
we have two pairs
and he wants them but he's trying to
budget and try not to waste money
man but i'm sorry i can't hear you i
think this is gonna do it
no it's like every little note
is just perfect you hear those little
tiny notes that you don't hear
oh and the deep bass too there's some
bass notes that
don't even play on cheaper speakers you
hear nothing
it's got everything you got the base the
mids the highs
it's all separated so well oh
oh man
oh man
oh my goodness that's crazy okay don't
listen anymore oh
man wow
everything's separated so there's a
couple of parts where like there's a
there's this that happens and it's weird
because i hear like the other
sounds in the background but the like
happens like it's
in my ears like separate like you're
saying a soundstage
that's these headphones are the best to
describe soundstage
different locations of where it's
playing and i don't know how it does it
you know what's interesting vadim
earlier you said you wish there were
separate tweeters
yeah do you still have that thought i
don't know how it's possible that
there's one driver
that is changing the location of the
sound in different notes
and there's like this little like
shaking almost like a rattlesnake
effect in there and it just happens like
almost inside your ear
closer to it and it's like mind-blowing
how
it just plays so well everything's so
clean like i
i want to listen to different songs i
know that's what right now
it's my turn i want to listen to old
songs that i used to love
oh man all right i sound like a fanboy
but
like i'm blown away like you guys have
to try these out in the apple store
no no no no i don't don't try it out at
the apple store
don't if you if you don't have the
budget
please don't go to the apple store
please don't try them on
because okay so i think vadim if you
want to answer the question
at the start that we had is the sound
worth 550
from that one song all right so to me i
know the homepod is expensive
but because it is just so good at
playing those notes that you usually
don't hear in the bass
i don't regret it at all yeah that's a
very good point so i think same thing
with
with these ones man like wow the home
pods are really expensive
but the people that bought them
everybody that i've talked to none of
them regretted it
same thing with the magic keyboard for
the ipad pro
if you can forget that you spent 300
bucks on it people love it i love it
and i think this is next with apple's
lineup if you can
get over the price tag or just forget
about it block it out
you're gonna really enjoy if especially
if you're a part of apple's
ecosystem so our final verdict
is going to be in our full review but
for now
these sound very impressive and not only
just the sound quality but just the
sound stage and the separation
that is the biggest thing that stands
out compared to everything else that i
have heard
and now let's go ahead and test out the
spatial audio i have
end game opened up right here i'm going
to click on the headphones
click spatial on all right so we can get
some surround
sound and with head tracking as well
we have noise cancellation turned on
it's so weird if you guys have never
experienced this
you the sound is from where you're
watching so if you turn your head
it's it's just localized exactly where
it needs to be
all right thanos nice deep rich
sound from his voice pretty good
when he throws a shield you hear just
going
yeah yeah that's a all right
these sound really good for movies as
well
that sounds fantastic now i'm going to
want to use these
whenever i watch a movie and now let's
go ahead and test out
how they work with the cable i did buy
it for 35 bucks but i wonder
before we do that can we run it with the
included cable a usbc
and then can we use this little adapter
so let's go ahead and
open this up first so get it out of the
packaging this is the cable that you use
to charge it and i really wish that they
went with usbc all around not lightning
but
hey that's apple and i'm going to go
ahead and remove it here
from the mac there you go so we have no
bluetooth connection
plug into the mac here and the other
side and this is actually a really thick
cable i know if you'd want to use it but
if you don't want to waste
extra money on top of that
let's plug it in and see what happens so
it looks like they
are charging but nothing really came up
on the mac itself let's go into
our settings and check out the sound
settings here
and it looks like they're not showing up
in the output or the input
so unfortunately they will not work with
this cable
it is just for charging so let's go
ahead and set that aside
now my next question before we open up
is the little adapter if you guys still
have a couple of these or maybe you guys
lost them but they are less expensive
than buying the actual cable
and we'll grab this cable which comes
with the sony's
thank you sony unlike apple let's go
ahead and connect them over here
and connect on this side all right they
did show
up we have external headphones right
there
so this might be a nice little hack all
right
unfortunately i have my volume turned up
here
nothing is muted in the sound section i
have the headphone
port selected but we're not getting
anything
select them again nope apple
you you're making us buy this 35
cable no workarounds at all no hacks so
let's go ahead and open up this little
box and
very flexible as well so that is good
has a decent length to it let's go ahead
and plug it in
we'll get this side as well
all right and it looks like
it didn't automatically switch so let's
go and switch to external headphones
and i don't have them paired to this
computer just to simulate how it is with
a computer that might not have bluetooth
and i'm hearing the music right now so
it's interesting when you have it
plugged in
with the cable and you you set the
macbook pro to the max volume right here
you set your song to the max volume it
was still kind of medium
you have to go to your actual headphones
and then use the digital crown
to adjust it all right there you go
that's loud right there that sounds
really good
all right so yes you are gonna have to
spend 35 bucks on apple's cable
i don't know if there's a dac built into
this this little part is pretty thick
and long maybe there is i know there's
some third parties for
20 bucks or so but if you're gonna spend
550 plus tax on these headphones you
might as well buy
apple's cable a couple more things
before i give you guys
my conclusion first off we only actually
went through
about uh four three four percent of
battery life that whole time listening
to music
and you guys may have thought and we
thought before that
with this toggle it could only go
between your
transparency mode and your active noise
cancellation mode
but actually if you go ahead and go into
the bluetooth settings
and you go into the airpods max you can
actually add
the off mode so you can add that on and
then it'll cycle between all three just
like the airpod
pros and with that um apple rates these
with 20 hours of battery life using the
active noise cancellation
but with the off mode you are going to
get even better battery life and if you
don't want to add that to
the toggle here you just press down on
the headphones in control center
press right over here and then just
select off now this is interesting this
is the first time i'm hearing it like
this
and a lot of my voice is actually
blocked even without active noise
cancellation
and i didn't know that was the case
because if you go to transparency my
voice sounds
exactly like it does in real life it's
crazy how good
that mode is alright guys now it is time
for the final
verdict let's go ahead and slip these
back into their
protective case i'm gonna stop calling
it the bra
and are these things worth 550 dollars
as far as the sound quality well you
know what
i knew they were going to sound good i
knew they were not going to sound bad
for this price that would be
unacceptable what i didn't know
is how wide the sound stage would be and
how dang
good the separation would be with single
drivers that's what i was not expecting
now my verdict or my conclusion is if
you're an iphone user
and you care about sound quality and you
want to over
the ear pair of headphones yes
absolutely
it is not only because the sound quality
is fantastic
you get all those extra features with it
that you won't get with other headphones
now with that said
if you're somebody that is an android
user or you're just using them with your
computer
that is where we are going to have to
compare them to the sony's
to bose maybe something else so if you
guys want to see that
click that little circle above and we
will be making
those videos so overall i want you guys
to let me know your thoughts as well
down in the comments
and you guys can check one of those
great videos right over there this has
been max and we'll see you in the next
video
you